we have a lot of room to grow regardless
of us being friends or wherever we stand
yeah it's a season of healing for
tristan thompson and khloe kardashian
the nba pro shared a cryptic message
about responsibility as the couple
awaits the arrival of baby number two
via surrogate on sunday tristan posted
some wisdom on instagram the park
grabbing fans attention rule number
three you have all responsibility in
your life yeah it's an interesting piece
of advice coming from the athlete on the
heels of his paternity scandal when he
cheated on chloe and had a son with
fitness model marylee nichols it's his
whole thing saying i'm tristan thompson
met this girl in houston i slept with
her on my 30th birthday so i sent it to
him and i said does chloe know about
this chloe doesn't even know and based
on the timeline tristan stepped out on
coco as they were seemingly working
things out and planning to expand their
own family as fans saw on season one of
the kardashians you know i want to you
know get us back together and build our
family and
hopefully be able to expand our family
one day god willing every day he tries
to show me and prove to me that he is
a different person and that i should
have faith and trust him meanwhile
chloe's been sharing a few equally
cryptic messages of her own she posted
an instagram story about being thankful
for the difficult times because those
times help you grow coco continued be
thankful for your mistakes they will
teach you valuable lessons and she says
gratitude can turn a negative into a
positive i'm focused on
work and like taking care of me my body
and soul and true yeah coco's main focus
is being the best mom to their
four-year-old daughter true and when it
comes to her ex she expects the same for
him to be the best dad exactly just last
week tristan was spotted out with a
mystery woman in greece but according to
a source coco's unfazed she even liked
an instagram post from a fan account
that shared footage of tristan hand in
hand with the woman seemingly agreeing
with the message in the caption that
they're both single and can do as they
please quote as long as he's a good dad
to his baby i think everyone has to
handle their co-parenting situation in
their own style we've learned chloe and
tristan only speak when they're
co-parenting and chloe has an open door
policy when it comes to visiting the
kids as the two prepare for the arrival
of their baby boy via surrogate i don't
know true's getting older and i just
feel like it's now time
to have another kid
yep
i like to hear another source tells e.t
chloe has been nesting for a while quote
she's very excited for true to have a
sibling and bring another baby into the
family and all the while coco's leaning
on her family for support especially mom
kris jenner who lives a few doors down
quote the family supported chloe in her
journey to have another child they are
extremely upset with tristan but they
know chloe did everything possible to
make it work with him chloe she's the
strongest girl i know she keeps
recovering forgiving
you know for the sake of her daughter
[Music]
you